aujourd'hui j'ai une interview jean luc
mélenchon le candidat de la france en
soumises et l'union populaire alors
petite présentation avant de commencer
jean luc mélenchon à 70 ans il s'est
engagé en politique très jeune à gauche
d'abord au parti socialiste il a
notamment été sénateur a 35 ans et puis
en 2008 il a créé son propre mouvement
le front de gauche devenu depuis la
france insoumise et depuis 2010 est il
est député des bouches du rhône c'est sa
troisième candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
après 2012 où il avait obtenu 11,1 pour
cent des voix et 2007 où il avait obtenu
19 6% des voix alors vous commencez à le
savoir mais le principe de l'interview
face cachée je vous le rappelle jean luc
mélenchon fait face à un écran géant sur
lequel défilent des émaux j à plusieurs
reprises pendant l'interview il appuie
sur le buzzer pour s'arrêter sur un
emoji dont la face cachée va arriver les
différents éléments qui seront à chaque
fois le point de départ de questions de
fond concernant son programme qui
s'appelle l'avenir en commun et sa
vision de la finance au passage d'une
interview a duré plus longtemps que
prévu et du coup pour respecter une
égalité de temps de parole entre tous
les candidats interviews et j'ai
supprimé une question à entière j'ai
choisi de retirer une question sur un
point qu'on avait déjà assez longuement
abordé dans la vidéo de décryptage du
programme de jean luc mélenchon en effet
je vous le rappelle là aussi ces
interviews face cachée viennent en
complément des décryptages de programmes
pour chacun des candidats l'objectif du
coup avec ses interviews c'est
d'apporter des précisions sur des sujets
qui font débat ou alors d'aborder
d'autres questions potentiellement moins
médiatisé est d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à cette chaîne youtube pour
ne pas rater les prochaines interviews
et les prochains décryptage de programme
je crois que j'ai tout dit je vous
laisse du coup avec la vidéo bonjour
jean luc mélenchon donc je vous remercie
beaucoup d'avoir accepté mon invitation
est ce que le principe et les règles
déjà de cette interview sont claires non
j'ai pas compris voulait que je
recommence chez vrai devoir revoir ses
stupides ou bois le pari a comprend qu
il vaut mieux les venues les expliqué au
début de tour du monde soit vous même
pour ceux qui nous regardent ceux ci
ceci pour eux on va voir du coup appuyé
quand vous le souhaitez aller
voilà c'est
donc d'accord 1 et mogi seller mogis
journal un article de presse va donc
s'afficher je vous propose de le
découvrir et de le lire à voix haute en
tête dans les sondages l'abstention
refuse toujours de déclarer sa
candidature vous l'aurez peut-être
compris deviné c'est un article d'un
journal parodique le bourg à 6 mais ça
pose une vraie question la ligue octobre
2021 exactement octobre 2021 ça pose en
l'occurrence une vraie question c'est la
question de l'abstention aux dernières
élections régionales l'abstention a
atteint un record pour une élection dans
la vème république 65 % des inscrits ne
sont pas allés voter et c'est encore
plus marquant chez les jeunes puisque
ses 87 % des 18-24 ans qui ne sont pas
allés voter par ailleurs dans le cadre
de la présidentielle en ce moment c'est
près de trois français sur 10 qui
prévoit de ne pas voter lors de cette
présidentielle selon un sondage aux
docks ça qui est paru en janvier
l'une des solutions que vous avancez
jean luc mélenchon pour mettre fin à
cette abstention c'est de mettre fin à
la cinquième république donc le régime
politique actuel pour passer la sixième
république en quoi est-ce que ça
aiderait à faire baisser la france a
c'est pas le seul majeur l'abstention a
là une cause il y en a une qui est
purement circonstancielle mais on parle
pas il ya 13 millions de personnes qui
sont pas inscrits ou mal inscrits si
vous êtes étudiant général vous êtes
inscrits chez vos parents est bon
dernier moment vous bio et a poussé
l'europe c'est trop compliqué faire une
procuration si vous voulez ya plein de
mécanismes qui pousse à s'abstenir pour
prier un mécanisme politique qu'est les
gens qui disent façon ça sert à rien
raconte ce qu'ils veulent ils font tous
de toute façon à la fin la même chose et
donc il ya l'idée que l'on ne contrôle
rien
et puis c'est pas que faut c'est une
constitution du trait vertical beaucoup
de pouvoir sur le président hype avec
notamment c'est énorme et c'est faux je
crois que les français se rendent même
plus compte dans quel pays au monde dont
les neuf ans en guerre avec un seul vote
c'est ce qui vient de nous arriver
au mali on a voté une fois de façon
marine
8 milliards sont des petits 3 millions
par jour normal qu'ils se disent c'est
une comédie alors changer la
constitution c'est à dire changer la
règle du jeu ça veut dire surtout quand
on fait une constitution que les gens
disent quels sont les droits de chaque
citoyen donc si vous voulez on se
redéfinit les uns par rapport aux autres
et puis ensuite on peut mettre en place
des outils nouveaux de démocratie celle
ci a été inventé en 1958 faut s'imaginer
que ça il ya un moment quoi avec de
gaulle à l'époque oui mais si vous
voulez avec que de gaulle mais avec 13
départements français qui deviennent
l'algérie indépendante avec des femmes
dont 10% à peine travail et cetera bref
un autre monde
donc remettre tout ça à l'ordre du jour
ppi étant de la démocratie puisque
contrairement à tous ceux qui disent que
les gens sont plus bêtes savent ou
croient rien de tout ça moi je crois que
celle inverse c'est justement parce que
celle inverse que j'aime pas qu'on me
foute 2 et donc concrètement vous parlez
de 6ème république qu'est ce que vous
imaginez pour cette nouvelle république
alors nouvelle pour cette soirée bat
déjà si vous voulez il ya une difficulté
c'est que si je dis voilà ce que je vous
propose dirty tofu nous tu nous dis
qu'on va faire une constitution écrite
donc c'est là qu'on fera une assemblée
pour ça l'assemblée de formation que ça
l'assemblée constituante ce que je peux
dire moi c'est les idées que mes amis
s'il m'en reste à ce moment-là
présenteront à ladite assemblée
constituante c'est des outils qui
permettent ya à la fois des institutions
stables parce que on peut pas vivre dans
le régime de l'assemblée générale
permanente ou de la barricade permanente
et puis des éléments qui permette au
peuple d'intervenir à tout le monde quel
élément le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et puis le référendum
révocatoire qui permet de virer à mais
lui j'ajoute que je suis pour le droit
de vote à 16 ans
obligatoire alors pas pour 16 ans
justement ce qui aurait 16 ans entre 16
et 18 déciderait si oui ou non ils vont
voter puisqu'il semble pas prêt bas ils
vont pas appuyer sur ce prix c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui on soit à 18 ans on
pas voir or le faisait pour le droit de
vote obligatoire à partir de 18 ans
ouais ok avant facultatif entre 16 et 18
oui parce qu'il faut respecter ça que y
aider jeunes gens qui sont déjà assez
conscient pour se dire non ça me dépasse
je n'ai pas d'avis je vais pas m'en
mêler je peux faire n'importe quoi pour
faire comme tout le monde mais il faut
bien se rendre compte que du coup il ça
au créé notre obligation si le vote est
obligatoire il faut reconnaître le vote
blanc ou le vote nul et en particulier
on peut imaginer des règles ça c'est
l'assemblée constituante qu'il décidera
du genre qui a pas ça comme pour
chambres d'hôtes hambourg comme en
sélection et petite question justement
sur cette 6ème république et sur la mise
en place vous l'avez vous avez parlé de
l'assemblée constituante donc l'objectif
c'est d'avoir un référendum qui va
permettre l'organisation pour
l'assemblée constituante est chargé de
rédiger cette nouvelle constitution qui
sera ensuite soumise au référendum ou
non c'est comme ça en général ce
processus il prend combien de temps
est-ce que vous avez déjà une idée du
temps que ça peut prendre bah moi
j'aimerais que ça prenne le moins de
temps possible mais bon une assemblée
constituante elle est le plus souvent
maîtresse d'elle-même on peut penser
qu'il y en a pour deux ans et longtemps
de votre côté et deux en plus ils font
ça proprement je veux dire si c'est pas
une un petit cénacle entre gens qui sont
fermes entre eux mais que comme j'ai vu
dans certains pays des délégations
viennent avec des dés de mangue dirait
des injonctions et tout ça bon mais ça
c'est forcément un organisme vivant une
constituante est donc en attendant
pendant ces deux ans disons vous
gouvernez vous êtes président de la
cinquième république et vous alerter les
mesures que vous voulez que voulait
mettre en place et pour bien comprendre
du coup une fois que cette constitution
de la sixième république et aux
nouveautés
quel est votre place du coup est ce que
ça veut dire qu'au bout de deux ans
pouvait quitter le pouvoir et ce que
vous risquez normalement quand quelqu'un
est élu il va au bout de son mandat
c'est à dire si je suis élu là c'est
pour cinq ans donc je serai légitime à
dire à mes amis bas ça commence une fois
que c'est fini je pense que c'est pas
raisonnable si il ya eu un référendum
pour dire oui on veut une constituante
qui a eu la constituante ensuite un
référendum pour dire oui on veut bien de
ce texte là bon je pense que s'accrocher
au pouvoir devient discutable donc moi
je pense que pendant deux ans ou trois
ans je pas le temps que ça prend la
constituante
je gouverne conformément à la
constitution actuelle en la respectant
pas ce que on peut pas comme ça dans un
claquement de doigts décider quelle
constitution n'existe plus et que en
attendant je fais ce que bon
donc pendant le temps en question je
gouverne d'après cette constitution et
après moi mon goût personnel c'est stop
la nouvelle s'applique très bien on va
passer à la question suivante on a donc
relancé la roue et je voulais cette
fille et quand vous le souhaitez pour
l'arrêter alors à découvrir sur quoi on
tombe
et on tombe cette fois ci sur un
téléphone on va voir ce qui se cache
derrière ce téléphone alors c'est en
l'occurrence je vais je vais vous aider
à le dire parce que c'est on n'arrive
pas forcément à lire doris c'est un ce
qu'on appelle un même donc une sorte de
blague en ligne avec quelqu'un qui se
retrouvent en difficulté face à
différents boutons sur chacun de ces
boutons on voit différents noms de
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
tous des candidats de gauche on voit
yannick jadot jean luc mélenchon on voit
pas mal de noms différents et ça montre
une difficultés que connaissent pas mal
de candidats à gauche aujourd'hui est la
raison pour laquelle ça me semble
intéressant de voir ce même c'est que on
a reçu beaucoup de messages ces derniers
jours de gens qui nous suivent qui
n'arrivent pas toujours à comprendre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a autant de
candidatures à gauche on peut en compter
entre 6 et 7 en or selon verra combien
arrive à avoir leurs parrainages mais
comment est ce que vous leur expliquez
un nombre de candidatures à gauche au
sein d'abord puisque l'on est en liberté
de parole toujours acide grosse blague
quand même de quoi le ch a fait dix mois
que ça dure à vous êtes trop nombreux ou
avait perdu d'avancé là on est à 40
jours et vous vous venez me demander si
il aurait pas moyen de marquer dans
l'est pas forcément d'alliances mais à
bon mais j'ai pas trop 17 comprendre
votre position par rapport à dos quand
c'est la géographie comme j'ai compris
la question qui m'est posée entendez la
réponse que je vous fais ma réponse est
de dire ça a duré des mois il ya eu un
paquet de nigauds qui sont laissés
prendre à cette histoire l'a écrite et
pleurer des grosses larmes pas
retournera bah oui c'est vrai on a perdu
d'avant et il y en a un qui
applaudissait dès demain dans son bureau
en se marrant c'est macron parce que ces
cas là me nourris de voir des
adversaires qui annonce avant même
qu'une élection lieu qu'elles ont perdue
après de premiers éléments deuxième
élément il ya la méconnaissance de
l'histoire
de gens qui avaient pas envie de la
raconter en réalité russie tient là il
est banal c'est un chiffre ordinaire la
gauche dans beaucoup de candidats et moi
je viens de la gauche comme vous le
savez j'ai passé toute ma vie dans la
gauche mais les fois où on a gagné c'est
jamais qu'une candidature ni qu on avait
une candidature unique an 65 en 1974 il
y en a vu d'autres d'ailleurs et tu peux
aussi unique que ça et puis on a perdu
et la fois où on était cinq ou six
françois mitterrand a gagné donc si vous
voulez y a je ne dis pas que c'est une
bonne chose je suis pas en train de
chasser pour dire juste les faits
montrent que tous ceux qui ont eu la
bêtise d'aller pleurer en cadence quand
on leur demande et ont fait qu'une chose
c'est servir leurs adversaires sans
parler d'union de la gauche parce que ça
n'a effectivement pas le sujet on a très
peu et ans de l'élection la question qui
revient souvent c'est les différences
sur le programme et sur vos raisons de
la france par exemple vous par rapport à
d'autres candidats par exemple par
rapport à un candidat comme fabien
roussel donc le candidat du parti
communiste quand on voit les programmes
beaucoup se posent la question de la
différence qu'est ce qui vous
différencie par exemple de fabien
roussel pour que j'en sais rien je sais
pas parce que j'ai fait deux campagnes
avec les communistes le programme a
évolué dans les deux cas mais cette fois
ci il a évolué mais évidemment avec le
temps on précise et où on était d'accord
sur bondy chose raisonnable c'est-à-dire
90% bon chacun des deux appelés 10% de
divergences avec le programme mais faut
bien s'entendre et puis là ils ont
décidé de démarrer tout seul on sait pas
pourquoi
sinon parce que ils ont pensé c'est leur
droit
il fallait qu'ils affirment la présence
communiste dans l'élection et depuis
alors monsieur fabien hausse elle dit
des choses sur nos désaccords moi je
note j'essaye de j'ai noté une fois été
marquée le il était content le revenu
universel ça tombe bien je le propose
pas une autre fois c'était il dit va
interdire de manger gras et salés ben
non je combats le manger gras et salés
parce que en effet ça rend malade les
gens aient d'abord les gens les plus
pauvres donc il ya alors il ya une
divergence celle-là oui j'ai repéré
c'est sur le nucléaire où on n'est pas
d'accord puisque lui est favorable
claire et moi je suis contre bon ben la
dernière fois on s'était accordé on
avait dit bon comme toutes les familles
politiques du pays sont partagés en
faisons un référendum et j'ai c'était la
condition de l'union moi j'accepte le
référendum est même question pareille
c'est pas pour parler d'alliance au
d'union mais votre distinction sur le
programme par rapport à yannick jadot on
peu voir pas mal de points communs
notamment environnementaux qu'est ce qui
vous différencie selon vos derniers
cadeaux va d'abord yannick jadot alors
sur le plan international est
complètement alignée sur les états unis
d'amérique c'est à dire que quoi que
disent les nord américains le dow est
d'accord avec
alors je le dis jusqu'à présent que
j'évite de rajouter à la polémique parce
que ça me saoule ça m'intéresse pas je
pense à fait pas avancer d'un mettre nos
idées respectives mais là je le dis
quand même parce que là en ce moment
dans une situation très tendue et moi ma
position c'est non-alignés ni poutine
l'hybride n a sûrement pas là lui c'est
baden baden et reus le diable tout ça ça
c'est pas très malin et pas très bien à
mon avis pas adaptée à la situation mais
il ya d'autres sujets sur lesquels on
n'est pas d'accord c'est souvent sur
l'international lui est un partisan
absolue de l'union européenne tout va
bien c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
mais pour son propre programme il est
obligé de dire des choses qui sont
incompatibles été traités alors moi je
lui ai dit mais coûteux si tu veux
vraiment par exemple faire du
protectionnisme même écologique dis-moi
comment tu fais qu'un traité européen
qu'il interdit donc je pense que ça si
j'arrive au deuxième tour il y aura
moyen de discuter parce que de mon côté
j'ai aussi fait un pas je la mets au
lieu de dire je veux plus entendre
parler de cette union européenne j'ai
dit banco il ya une chose que je veux
c'est mon programme s'applique point
barre le reste on verra après tout la
renégociation potentiel des traités
européens annonceront marge et vous
verrez boisseau ça sera ça sera aux
mains liées parce que non seulement
contenu est intenable on l'a bien vu sa
part et c'est la règle pour que les gens
ci dessus bien c'est notamment ce qu'on
appelle la règle des 3% qui les
engendrent s'est réduit alors c'est le
lan % de déficit est respectée c'est la
règle qui dit que le libre échange
généraliser non seulement à l'intérieur
de l'union mais avec le reste du monde
qui détruit tous les pays et les traiter
avec ma fille je prends un exemple
qu'ils achètent tous les droits de pêche
au sénégal ou dans d'autres pays comme
ça ramasse tous les poissons qui alla
tous les gens qui vivent le long de la
côte ils ont plus la langue attiré passé
tout ce qui leur reste donc si vous
voulez y ait un effet pervers on va être
sympa on va dire peut-être qu'au début
on pouvait pas l'imaginer mais
maintenant tout le monde l'a compris
donc moi j'ai bon espoir qu'à la fin les
points de vue se rapprochent et de
toutes façons de la chose dont je suis
sûr c'est que les traités seront
renégociés y compris par les gens qui
les aiment beaucoup aujourd'hui tout
gerland ça tient pas debout on va passer
à la question suivante je vous laisse du
coup à nous appuyer sur cette source
buzzer
et c'est un chronomètre toujours un
exercice pas forcément évident en fait
je vais vous poser une série de
questions il faudra répondre par oui ou
par non à un maximum de questions en une
minute j'en suis conscient que ce n'est
pas un exercice très intelligent alors
le sont pas forcément d'accord je suis
pas d'accord je suis d'accord quand
c'est des questions très complexes mais
quand c'est des questions à deux courts
en ciment répond par léopard longtemps
pour moi je me semble intéressant pour
justement mieux connaître votre
programme sur certains aspects qu'on va
voir ici et on va pouvoir en parler
voyons brouillon première question
faut-il légaliser le cannabis oui
faut-il augmenter le smic à 1400 euros
oui faut-il revenir sur la 1400 m
faut-il revenir sur la réforme du bac
doit-on pouvoir prendre l'avion pour
faire un paris marseille
ira
très bien la police at-elle trop de
pouvoirs que la france doit-elle rester
dans l'otan non faut-il aller sur mars
oui faut-il réduire le nombre de députés
et de sénateurs
sinon pourquoi sommes nous en démocratie
aujourd'hui pas facile celle là bas
suivant un organisme international au
néant pas très belle démontration pas
passionnant oui non j'en suis consciente
elle signe le pass vaccinale est une
bonne chose non la corse devrait elle
être indépendante ben non papa bout un
mois via des corses oui par contre qu'on
doit changer leur statut ça c'est clair
faut-il rétablir l'uniforme à l'école
on va dire non parce que ya plus
d'inconvénients que d'avantagés
c'est un débat qui revint beaucoup jour
puisque toutes parts et les graines
d'une image du passé avait dit que l'on
dira je t'aimais avant tu parles que
j'étais avant dont je peux vous dire que
t'es pas mieux on va passer à la
question suivante on vous laisse encore
une fois habillé sur le buzzer
c'est donc le jeu des cadeaux un cadeau
mais en france c'est une question
derrière ce cadeau qui a été laissée par
un autre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
je vous propose donc d'écouter la
question est ensuite d'y répondre
directement
jean luc mélenchon vous exprimé un
intérêt non dissimulé pour
l'environnement et nous le concevons
tous parce que c'est une planète dont il
s'agit mais pour le coup je ne comprends
pas du tout votre position sur le
nucléaire le nucléaire est aujourd'hui
précisément l'élément de production
d'une énergie décarbonée ces mêmes
l'énergie la plus décarbonée donc
pourquoi s'opposer à ce point au
nucléaire qui est peu chère qui permet
justement de l'électricité peu cher et
qui est une industrie qu'on maîtrise sur
le bout des doigts d'abord
merci pour la question parce que en
effet cinq ados en fait c'est pas un
argument idéologique que j'ai contre le
nucléaire il ya des gens qui disent dans
le nucléaire c'est encore un truc super
verticale qui poussa un flicage
généralisé par mon point de vue moi mon
point de vue c'est assez dangereux c'est
trop dangereux on pourrait dire avant on
ne sait pas on arrête tu exagères bon
c'est dangereux parce que c'est un
système qui est assez rustique c'est une
cocotte minute avec des circuits bon
c'est assez simple mais comme ça cache
la catastrophe est totale il ya beaucoup
de choses qui poussent à ce que ce soit
plus fragiles 1 c'est qu'elles sont
toutes très vieille nos centrales jeu
là dans les cinq ans qui viennent y en a
17 de plus qui seront encore ont dépassé
l'âge limite c'est un premier élément
deuxièmement il ya le climat qui changea
tout à l'air de s'en [ __ ] mais je
signale que comme l'eau et plus en plus
chaudes on est obligé d'arrêter de plus
en plus souvent parce que
ne refroidit plus les centrales
nucléaires le climat le change et le
danger quand il a lieu je dis pas que je
veux pas non plus affoler les gens mais
c'est 100% kata donc mettez vous dans la
situation va donner 7 0 à écouter
regarder la région parisienne devant la
centrale de nogent il ya un pet 12
millions de personnes à déplacer la
centrale de la blague les standards de
sécurité aujourd'hui sont très élevés en
tout cas beaucoup plus élevé qu'il ne
l'était à d'autres à d'autres époques et
c'est ce que ce qu'affirme en tout cas
ceux qui défendent le nucléaire il
affirme que niveau sécurité il ya
beaucoup du mieux par rapport il ya du
mieux par rapport à ce qui se faisait
jusqu'ici ils avancent si d'autres
arguments l'argument de la stabilité est
l'argument qu'on a entendu là avec
marine le pen du fait que c'est une
énergie effectivement qui est peu
émettrices de co2 seul cd arguments qui
peuvent être convaincant dans la
situation à laquelle j'avais droit
d'être convaincu par ce que vous voulez
mais moi je sais des arguments qui
reviennent souvent dans des corps si
vous voulez je réponds à 1 allée j alors
la première premier argument c'est la
question de la peu émettrices de co2
argument avancé par le giec notamment
kapoor cantons à l'exception d'un sénat
fait le total de tout ce que ça coûte en
énergie
pour fabriquer la centrale pour couler
le béton pour installer les choses une
fois qu'on a les déchets qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait personne n'en sait rien mais je
redonne ma question vous préférez quoi
douze millions de personnes déplacées ou
pas de personnes déplacées le sujet
n'est pas de savoir si c'était
carbonnier ou pas c'est de savoir si
c'est dangereux ou pas c'est plus
dangereux que ça n'a jamais été et
depuis tchernobyl et depuis chaque
oshima on sait que c'est très dangereux
et du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait trop de
choses mais bon c'est incroyable ça on
croirait que le monde n'existait pas
avant qu'ils aient du nucléaire et qui
n'existera pas après qu'on n'est arrêté
mais c'est un débat dans la
présidentielle c'est pour ça que les
personnes je vous ai compris à gauche
d'ailleurs n'empêche pas de poser la
question je je je vous demande
d'entendre l'ordre de mes réponses on
nous dit c'est une énergie indépendante
c'est pareil a pas d'uranium en france
faut aller aller les chercher et vous
savez à quel prix elle et rhône isère
notamment au niger notamment mais c'est
pas là que c'est le plus ennuyeux c'est
le kazakhstan parce que c'est un
dictateur qui est là-bas en place et que
on cotise pour pour cet homme alors
après ce n'est pas vrai que c'est comme
une énergie constant deuxièmement elle a
dit c'est ce qu'il ya de moins cher
c'est pas vrai on est absolument certain
marqué tout sur le papier absolument
certain que en
2030 un peu avant d'ailleurs dans 25 je
crois le l'éolien coûtera moins cher que
le nucléaire de toute façon je redis aux
gens écouter ya le risque et puis
deuxièmement qu'est ce que vous faites
des déchets mais personne n'en parle
aujourd'hui on est arrivé au maximum à
l'ags du stockage on veut en mai tabur
tous m'ont dit les projets
d'enfouissement ce terrain avant
j'aurais donc ça me paraît pas
raisonnable comme a dit le président de
la république je vais vous faire 14 père
de plus c'est pas mal je suis là y en a
pas un qui marchent de pair le seul
qu'on en construction il a dix ans de
retard et 10 milliards de rab bon tout
ça n'est pas sérieux ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il ya des besoins en énergie
aujourd'hui qui sont très importants ça
c'est le cas ça risque d'augmenter aussi
dans les années qui viennent malgré les
économies d'énergie comme vouloir faire
comment est-ce que du coup on s'assure
d'avoir et bien cette énergie qui est
elle a certes évoqué la transition que
vous proposez bah écoute et déjà
commençons par dire une chose j'ai pas
l'intention d'arrêter les centrales
nucléaires comme ça en arrivant à
l'elysée ça n'a pas de sens donc on
arrêtera à mesure qu'on aura les relais
moi je suis pour que les relais il le
plus vite possible quelles sont ses
relais possible il ya l'énergie qui se
trouve dans la terre il ya l'énergie qui
se trouve qui vient du soleil on connaît
tout ça et moi mon chouchou c'est
l'énergie en mer alors c'est d'une part
les éoliennes offshore c'est à 20 km de
la côte c'est supportable il y a le
l'énergie dit mme de la marée 1 2 du
mouvement de la mer c'est 66 fois ce
dont on a besoin à terre ça c'est
gratuit et c'est là tous les jours
kenneth tu pleures qui vante il à celle
dont j'ai dit qu'il vient de la holy à
l'énergie qui vient du show à la surface
de la mer et du froid au fond qui fait
tourner d'immenses machine bord vous me
direz elles sont où vos machines
battalions mais en train de les faire
aujourd'hui on a installé on a une
première éolienne offshore c'est la
seule qu'on a c'est quand même la honte
totale pour les français il n'a plus de
1000 la bad en or nous on a eu l
expérimental mais elle marche avec des
pales de seulement 40 mètres l'idée
c'est qu'on est des pales qui fasse 120
m donc on aura ninard machine de 140 m
vous imaginez ça brasse et comme c'est
un maire c'est beaucoup plus régulier
comme si au large que si vous le mettez
à terre ou ça casse les pieds à tout le
monde et des histoires sans fin et où
c'est beaucoup plus intermittent donc je
demande qu'on comprenne que quand on
veut on peut notre pays a été je veux
pas prendre de mauvais exemple c'est
souvent en guerre il savait trouver les
moyens de construire ce qu'il fallait
pas me dites pas que c'est une affaire
d'installer des parcs d'éoliennes en mer
à 20 bornes de la côte tout le long a
mis km de côtes savoir à votre tour
d'ailleurs je vous propose de poser une
question du coût à une candidate à
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
vous avez une question à poser à anne
hidalgo la candidate du parti socialiste
vaujour anne hidalgo comme vous le savez
la première fois qu'on a inventé la
retraite c'était en 1910 c'était à 65
ans et puis ensuite on a amélioré sa au
fur et à mesure du temps parce que la
bataille pour la diminution du temps de
travail c'est la bataille constitutive
du mouvement socialiste aujourd'hui
encore on pourrait partager le temps de
travail mieux pour travailler tous voilà
alors pourquoi vous accrochez vous à la
retraite à 62 ans avec 43 annuités à
payer ça veut dire que pour les jeunes
gens qui commencent comme c'est la
moyenne à 23 ans ça leur fait la
retraite à 66 ans est ce que ça c'est
une politique socialiste je crois pas et
je pense que vous pensez comme moi on va
passer à la question suivante donc là
concrètement c'est une bulle aider à
cette bulle il va y avoir en
l'occurrence une phrase qui a été
prononcé par un autre candidat est-ce
que vous avez une idée de qui aurait
prononcé ces mots là c'est le dictateur
poutine qui menacent la démocratie
ukrainienne il faut maintenir les
menaces et sanctionner le ligue archi
corrompu russe est-ce que vous avez une
idée de qui aurait pu prononcer ces mots
ça peut être beaucoup n'emporte lequel
des gens qui sont alignés sur le
vocabulaire de la guerre moi je suis
pour une position non-alignés vers en
charge ne passe pas la frontière les
american and expo luxe c'est donc en
l'occurrence pour que tout le monde et
le contexte yannick jadot qui a prononcé
ces mots le 28 janvier 2022 ça fait écho
à la discussion qu'on avait tout à
l'heure sur la question de l'ukraine
notre position c'est la suivante celle
d'un la démocratie ukrainienne et on y
va fort parce que c'est vrai que le
président d'ukraine a agréablement
surpris tout le monde hier les hans qui
wells est un acteur de cinéma et l'envié
ce gala et j'aimais tiendra le coup mais
fait preuve de beaucoup de sang-froid
sûr mais dire que c'est une démocratie
en ukraine c'est aussi sur la question
de du non alignement vous venez de
l'évoquer qu en quoi ça consiste très
concrètement un nom à nouveau dans cette
situation la première d'abord il faut
partir de l'idée comment le monde est
organisée il a été longtemps entre
l'urss et les états unis d'amérique où
globalement le camp communiste et le
camp capitaliste parce qu'il faut
compter la chine là dedans bon cet ordre
du monde s'est disloqué aujourd'hui
l'ordre du monde reste dominée
militairement par les états unis
d'amérique qui représente 50 % des
dépenses militaires du monde 80% avec
leurs alliés mais c'est un empire qui
est fragilisé et qui est en train qui
est entré en déclin avec la sinne
notamment et d'autres allaient de
terrines et d'autre et alors comme ils
ont du mal à se mettre d'accord déjà
entre eux sur ce qu'il faut faire les
uns disent le problème c'est les russes
nous ont d'habitude et les dix ans et
les chinois résultat ils font les deux à
la fois ce qui est totalement stupide
parce que ça pousse les russes dans les
bras des chinois et vice versa m'enfin
c'est leur affaire nous les français de
courant des comptables de nous intérêt à
nous français est notre premier intérêt
c'est que l'europe se transforme pas en
champ de bataille donc moi je suis pour
que la france soit un pays non alignés
quand il ya un problème nous ne sommes
pas systématiquement avec l'un ou avec
l'autre nous regardons nous intervenons
et nous inspirons confiance parce que
nous ne sommes pas ligne et donc nous
pouvons être un interlocuteur acceptés
par les uns et par les autres et surtout
nous français on défend nos propres
intérêts d'abord est donc là dans la
situation actuelle avec un pays comme
l'ukraine il ya la question par exemple
de l'otan on n'a compté que vous
souhaitez que la france sorte de l'auto
est donc cette alliance militaire marche
avait mené vers les états unis oui vous
savez dire pas d'invasion de l'ukraine
par la russie mais ça veut dire pas non
plus de l'annexion de l'otan dans le
cadre de pardon de l'ukraine dans le
cadre de l'otan passer une aversion pour
vous si le barreau et
il bien sûr bien sûr une fois vous êtes
là dedans c'est fini vous décidez de
plus rien à regarder les européens sont
tous dans l'otan quand on de la france
notamment la france est annexée
aujourd'hui par les états unis pour
comprendre le pour sa défense évidemment
la preuve une lettre quand ils veulent
ils ont décidé par exemple
on sait pas nous qui aurions les choix
des australiens on a été mis dehors mais
comme il est comme ça allez hop on
rentre à la maison chez vous et vos
contrats aidés sur l'opération barkan
par exemple c'est une opération qui est
menée par la france ça peut être un
exemple il ya c'est une opération qui
est menée par la france vont pouvoir
d'annexion de l'armée française de la
défense et qu'on sait c'est vrai qu'ils
sont forts ouais bien sûr c'est des mots
qui sont forts la preuve c'est que vous
ferez la guerre jeune homme si jamais
les états unis d'amérique ont décidé de
se taper avec les russes vous êtes
contents non d'autres comme moi vous
dites c'est un moyen d'éviter ça pour
une sortie de l'otan et plus
généralement non animaux et mais il faut
en allant vers siel bleu il faut
comprendre ce qu on apporterait au monde
c'est pas seulement qu' on dirait nous
français on est plus les petits soldats
de plomb des nord américains mais c'est
que on serait écoutée écoutable pour
faire des propositions par exemple moi
je dis le non-alignement doit nous
permettre d'avoir une diplomatie
altermondialiste qu'est ce que c'est ça
veut dire par exemple défendre le le
tribunal international que les boliviens
ont proposé contre le crime déco side ça
veut dire que
vous allez sur un traité international
de mont diffusion des énergies carbonées
mais vous êtes crédibles comme vous
dites ça si vous amenez en dire en a
besoin dans le commandement militaire
intégré des américains il vous répond ce
que disent qu'ils sont des alliés
aujourd'hui si jamais il faut sortir de
l'otan qui seraient nos alliés selon
vous alliez pour vous faire à l'idée que
je sois militaires par exemple vous
parler notamment d'alliance
altermondialiste un terme que vous avez
beaucoup utilisé ce serait quel pays
selon ce que je viens d'évoquer il y en
a des dizaines dans le monde mais
comprenez-moi bien déjà votre
vocabulaire et curieux des alliés pour
quoi faire
dans paix il peut y avoir rejeté la
lutte contre le terrorisme ça peut être
un exemple ça fait des alliances
économiques d'ailleurs aussi un selon
les selon les alliances le la lutte
contre le terrorisme tout le monde est à
lier le monde entier alliés ça donne
d'ailleurs lieu à des débordements qui
sont très discutables sur ce qui se fait
dans un certain nombre de pays soussou
couleurs de lutte contre le terrorisme
je pense aux ouïghours en chine au
rwanda en birmanie j'en passe et des
meilleurs les yéménites et le reste bon
donc ça c'est pas un sujet en général
tout le monde et alliés se passe des
renseignements les leersois quoi je
pense moi c'est ce qui serait nos alliés
pour faire avancer des idées qui
l'emmenait en direct dans les bouquins à
ce moment là vous allez trouver des
dizaines de pays parce que toute
l'amérique latine d'accord pour faire
reconnaître le crime déco side les états
unis veulent pas nous pourrions avoir
des alliés pour faire appliquer par
exemple la convention internationale de
l'oit et sur le droit des enfants au
travail les états unis d'amérique ne
veulent pas ou des handicapés états unis
d'amérique ne veulent pas ça il peut y
avoir des alliances et à partir de là
vous fait avancer le débat mais vous
êtes respecter parce qu'on dit barreaux
ils sont avec personne ils sont d'accord
qui seront libres de décider à la
rosière saxe souligne un lien entre
non-alignés et diplomatie
altermondialistes et je gagne moi je je
voudrais qu'on comprenne que mon point
de vue il est fondé sur une analyse de
l'histoire une puissance déclinante mais
tous les autres en danger c'est ce qui
se passe avec les états unis d'amérique
ne se veut pas dire pour autant que je
trouve les autres sympathiques ans c'est
pas ça que je pense que la bonne
politique c'est le réalisme on a compris
votre position sur ce sujet on l'a passé
à la question suivante toujours la même
chose je vous invite appuyée sur le
buzzer
c'est une est gentil toujours un petit
décalage c'est une vidéo qu'on va
regarder ensemble et ensuite je vous
propose d'y réagir je vous poser une
petite question sur ce sujet là je
m'engage approfondir la lutte contre les
exclusions pour aller vers cet objectif
géraud fdl je veux si je suis élu
président de la république que d'ici à
deux ans plus personne ne soit obligé de
dormir sur le trottoir
je ne veux plus d'ici la fin de l'année
à voir des femmes et des hommes
dans les rues
dans les bois j'en appelle en font la
promesse de 0 cendres sans abri c'est
une promesse que vous portez vous avez
eu l'occasion de développer notamment à
la fondation abbé pierre il y a quelques
jours c'est un sujet vous le voyez qui
est présent depuis des dizaines d'années
dans là dans la campagne présidentielle
en général qui aussi touche beaucoup de
personnes puisque on est tous forcément
ça insupportable de voir des gens qui
dorment encore la rue par centaines de
milliers
très concrètement sur ce sujet là
pourquoi est-ce qu'on devrait vous
croire selon vous d'abord faut croire
personne sur parole
moi je dis juste une chose vous voyez
écrire autre chose ou ne rien écrire
dire l'accent sur la mise en place à
temps d écouter la question d'une guide
pourquoi je dois vous croire moi je vous
explique le contourner candidat à une
fonction comme celle là que auparavant
je ne sais que vous croire sur capable
de mettre en place les mesures les
bonnes mesures qui permettent de lutter
contre parce que ce qu'on voit c'est un
certain nombre de présents la république
notamment ouais on portait ce message là
il n'y a plus à voir des avancées mais
de là à parler de zéro sans abri
effectivement on y est on y annonce ou
après les trois cent mille 100 avant dix
ans mais remettons les choses à leur
place il ya de plus en plus de monde que
sans abri c'est à dire que j'ai passé le
contraire de ce qu'il voulait rassembler
sans abri aujourd'hui en france à ce
deal c'était des gros menteur il faisait
exprès avec cynisme ou se dire ils n'ont
pas utilisé la bonne méthode ou se dire
de toute façon le laissant le sans
abrisme est le résultat de la pause a
doublé en dix ans ce qui montre que
c'est un projet auquel évoluent pour
accepter que l'immobilier soit à marcher
comme un autre et faciliter le rôle
particulier du marché de l'immobilier
sur l'accumulation imaginez vous à paris
moi dans la rue dans laquelle je suis je
suis pas loin de la gare de l'est on en
est en juillet euros du mètre carré j'ai
donc vu le mètre carré que j'ai acheté
au départ augmenté de 350 % en l'espace
de dix ans je n'ai rien fait on n'a pas
balayé la rue mieux on n'a pas mis des
bords de trottoirs en diamants je sais
pas quoi
on voit bien que c'est purement
spéculatif d'accord ceux qui ont accepté
que ça aille jusqu'à ce point devait
admettre l'idée que du coup à l'autre
bout de la chaîne il y aurait des gens
que plus qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ce
sens cowes week concrètement et
immédiatement et tout de suite alors j'y
viens non pas forcément mais c'est
une urgence en même temps c'est un prime
qui est majeure ouais il ya deux mille
personnes tous les ans qui meurent de la
rue donc si vous voulez moi je trouve
qu'il ya une forme de désinvolture à
l'égard de sa comme à l'égard des morts
au travail ça fait trois ans que j'en
parle autant que je peux 560 personnes
sur le poste de travail pour la première
fois on a vu un journal en faire sa une
y'a pas longtemps ces libérations et je
veux le saluer là c'est pareil on s'est
habitué 2000 morts de la rue par an
alors peut-être qu'on peut imaginer des
choses aussi compliquée que
réquisitionner les logements vides il ya
trois millions de logements vides
admettons comme le dit l'abbé pierre la
fondation abbé pierre qui a un roulement
en réalité il y en a que 1 millions qui
sont libres depuis trois ans je si je
dis je vais tous réquisitionnés je vous
garantis qu'il est lourd on et que du
coup on aura des gens qui seront mieux
logés pas forcément ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont dans la rue 1 mais du coup ça c'est
de la place pour ceux qui sont dans la
rue dans les logements ensuite c'est la
réquisition deuxième élément c'est créer
ce qu'on appelle des pensions de famille
aujourd'hui il y en a une vingtaine de
milliers de places et donc on veut
arriver à 100 milles tech n ont pas
considérer alors une pension de famille
il faut que vous compreniez quelque
chose qui est un peu difficile à dire et
admettre c'est quelqu'un qui est dans la
rue la grande difficulté souvent c'est à
se réhabituer à avoir une vie avec un
appart à s'occuper des choses comme ça
donc la pension de famille c'est à la
fois vous êtes autonome vous être
respectée vous êtes libres 1 vous êtes
libre mais il ya d'accompagnement delà
du maine membres âgés avec deux
personnes des escales gold gens vous
apprenez bon à vous retrouver les règles
de fonctionnement et puis il ya surtout
construire du logement parce que la
meilleure solution j'accompagne le
besoin c'est de leur donner un logement
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans le
programme on prévoit de monter à 200
milles lej ont créé par an aujourd'hui
on est à peine à 100 milles
bon 200 milles j'ai connu une époque
dans les années 70 sur 9 300 milles donc
ça n'a rien dit n'atteignait bhl moi je
pense que c'est pas possible qu'ils
aient 300 milles sans abri dans un pays
qui à notre puissance et sa richesse bon
mais il faut s'atteler à ça en disant on
va y mettre des moyens financiers ça
c'est pas le plus important mais surtout
des moyens humains pour décider suivre
les mesures que l'on prend on doit en
tout cas moi je ne vois pas ce que
quelqu'un d'honnête peut afficher comme
autre objectif que zéro sdf ou alors mon
médicaux mais en en laisse mais personne
n'osera dire ça donc si vous dites zero
alors dit comment voilà moi je viens de
vous expliquer comment je pense qu'on
peut le faire et que on peut le faire si
bon à la volonté est là pour avoir la
volonté c'est pour ça que c'était un
sujet qui me semblait essentiel avec
aujourd'hui par mis à l'essai de
l'occasion qui né un peu ça permet de
parler et de faire prendre conscience
aux gens de la détresse qui nous entoure
et des 308 avril gens qui sont à l'aide
alimentaire 12 millions qu'on froid qui
chauffe pas on y en ait un grand pays
tout ça est une histoire de fou on va
passer à la à la dernière question je
vous invite à vienne dernière phase
hurle sur le buzzer et c'est ce sera le
drapeau français pour terminer alors
concrètement d'art ce drapeau français
lille et m pour conclure on va dire cet
échange est mieux comprendre enfin
monsieur olympio l'occasion de le faire
pendant ce temps là votre vision de la
france de reprendre une formule que vous
connaissez très sûrement enfin vous
connaissez sans aucun doute c'est celle
de françois hollande qui a été prononcée
en 2012 le fameux mois président qui a
été prononcée en 2012 face à nicolas
sarkozy le principe est assez simple des
phrases des séries de phrases vont
s'afficher à l'écran je vous propose de
les compléter comme vous le souhaitez à
chaque fois en une phrase de la lyre et
de la contacter histoire de comprendre
notre vision de la france et c'est là
que le début de la phrase et on va et
donc voilà je vous laisse salir et la
complète en une phrase au mois pour
résidents les jeunes seront appelés à se
rendre utile mois président mon ennemi
sera beau je le laisse découvrir
lui-même
passer au suivant
vous occupez des pauvres gens
les plus riches
paieront plus ils se sont moqués
regorgent et là c'est en dernier donc il
faut partager la et enfin un dernier
mois président la france
sera assez aimée par tous les français
pour que des gens arrêtent de se
détester intrus merci beaucoup jean luc
mélenchon d'avoir pris le temps de venir
échanger avec nous on a abordé un
certain nombre de sujets je précise du
coût thématiques que cet échange qu'on a
pu avoir vient en complément d'une autre
vidéo une vidéo de décryptage de
présentation de votre programme on se
penche sur un certain nombre de
dirigeants précisent que je n'ai pas vu
la vidéo donc c'est sous sa
responsabilité pour la mini trêve ne
remet pas c'est pas facile de d le
programme donne au triage pas combien
690 mesure moi même vous pas de boucler
toutes les expliquer parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d' expertise dedans je sais que
c'est dur souvent de présenter ses
complexes ça a été mais vous inviterai
du koala à la voir on a présenté une
dizaine de mesures que vous que vous
portez merci pour votre temps jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui je résous à
chanceux truc toutes ses formes et ses
stars romance et sobre ya pas de
m'afficher rien pire choix que j'ai des
gestes de titres pires angoisses et
parce que je me suis remis doigts non
mais vous souhaitez l'occasion de parler
de sujets de fond pendant ce test
intéressant de pouvoir d'or noir qui la
juge à qui brûlent ou et moi et moi mais
ça va au moins on n'est pas déconcentré
c'est clair qu'on n'est pas déconcentrer
je précise d'ailleurs pour ce qui
regarde cette vidéo que pour attendait
qu'on est sur youtube pour découvrir les
autres interviews des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle mon corps et
décryptage des autres programmes des
candidats je vous invite à le voir
directement sur cette chaîne youtube
vous aussi vous abonner pour ne pas
louper les vidéos suivantes on met en
descriptions des liens pour un sort plus
en l'occurrence dans le cas de six
interviews sur le programme de jean luc
mélenchon merci encore pour votre
présence aujourd'hui on suivra donc avec
attention la suite de la campagne